- Oh, hi Harper.
What do, what is that?
- Get down Mr. President!
(screaming)
- This is actually a
Barefoot Contessa recipe,
it took me three and a
half hours to make it.
Cooking my food is like
actually kind of therapeutic.
Oh wait, no, I'm doing it.
- Last one dude.
- Get down Mr. President!
(screaming)
- Elliott, a vendor just
called up at the front desk,
you wanna come join us on this one?
- Okay.
Is this a trap?
- Elliott, it's a work phone call.
Come on bud, let's go.
- Okay, if this is the game,
I don't have health insurance.
- I know, it's amazing actually.
- Hi, this is Elliott speaking.
- [Voiceover] Hey Elliott,
get down Mr. President.
- Caylen?
It was a trap.
- Get down Mr. President!
(standoff music)
- I did it, I did it, I'm playing.
- What's going on?
Why aren't we working?
- Get down Mr. President!
I actually sing Elton John songs
to my lunch after I make them,
you can taste the love, it tastes better.